welcome back to some more
happy wheels let's see how this goes
shall we
can we gowns that sounds pretty funny
exit
the vehicle of war wait i'm in the
vehicle of war
whoa that's what you get you little
barrel
what are they doing all right i'm can i
shoot
why didn't they die
blood and kale there we go
die all of you
oh sorry sat down
i'm freaking out over here holy [ __ ] i'm
falling out
oh no it's [ __ ] me make it stop oh
my
god oh not my leg is [ __ ] my what is
my head exactly
well that's fantastic on vehicle version
three
well it's a lot of vehicles here ah
oh that did not go as planned did it
that's okay
all right i'm ready oh back flip
double backflip whoa whoa hey all right
uncomfortable
this is how i kill people all right is
this tron
mode on this the car is great
transaction
the car is also capable of what the hell
whoa yay oh [ __ ] me i lost my head
that's okay come back here head there we
go
come on let's go to narnia whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa there we go
let's kill some sons of [ __ ] front
flip whoa
ah god damn it dolphin mode activate
come on come on you can do this this car
is great
front flip yeah that's how i roll
[ __ ] can i kill people with this
crossbar thing or what
i want to kill people guns don't kill
people
dolphins kill people oh so sorry so
sorry it's not me it's a vehicle
i swear to god oh it's out of control
all right pretty cool vehicle by intense
stretch ooh
i love these i love these what
dad i hate you whoa i'm still alive
yay i'm oh no i'm not a foot that's not
a foot
shut up oh i got you dad no
no i will kill you you little [ __ ]
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
yeah yeah
this is not synchronized dads this is my
pain of agony white
that makes that sense all right
whoa oh god
whoa i got my foot let's party hard with
my foot yay
party hard damn what do you do do some
partying with my foot
whoa back flip dad let me go
dad i don't want to die let me go you
piece of [ __ ]
dad please don't won't you let me go let
me go
tonight don't got dad
don't hear anything all right cool that
was totally cool
what whoa backflip
back clip cannonball
whoa what the hell is supposed to do
here am i thinking oh
god daddy okay yes i'm totally fine this
is nothing
just a flesh wound all right let's i
think we need like santa claus or some
other character up in this
yeah yeah i'm [ __ ] santa claus that's
how i roll
that's how i get all the ladies i was in
the club
there we go there we go all right whoa
no he died now he died best but don't
leave me
whoa whoa whoa whoa ah i'm alive it's a
miracle oh no i'm not alive anymore
i love i'm sorry but i love that screen
all right there we go whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa it feels good
ah yeah i like this
i could do this all day yes if only
vespa was here
i would just just splendid all right
that was not bad not bad at all
let me play it most copper
what the hell is this i'm badass
this is badassery on a new level holy
shookers
oh my god my life is just totally
changed here
ah all right
just kidding go here collected the coin
and collect four of them
said slow but i didn't slow down but i
didn't die anyway what
i need that [ __ ] wait am i falling off
my god is that in my arm or a piece of
[ __ ]
it's okay got a new penis growing out of
me hey
what the hell is going on here oh wow
what is he doing
what are you going to new adventures
new adventures with them it's like he's
giving birth to a baby or something
like done in okay all right son
let's try and cross this [ __ ] it's not
gonna ah
where did you go whoa sorry about that
all right son i got an
idea you might not like it what is it
you what do you mean you want me to go
first don't you
well yes pretty much all right
okay go first son out of the water
please
please i don't want to go you have to
tell your little [ __ ]
i will let go you let that [ __ ] dead
please
i'm scared i don't want to do it okay
come here let's 69 is no
that's not 69 okay this is freaking um i
like that
yes let me look don't try to sexually
bribe me go you little [ __ ]
god damn it that didn't work all right
let's do some synchronized fans yeah
but we need some music what the hell is
this
[ __ ] i like
shut up this is so gay
i hate this why are you doing this to me
son
i'm kidding myself this is how much i
hate this
and i miss you and now i want
and i'm sayonara i hate this [ __ ]
into the sky
[ __ ] god damn it can i still make it
all right let's try this one more time
it's gonna throw you just
dead please don't do it just shut up
ah i knew you knew that's not how i hit
don't stand on my face
you little ah
come on son you gotta do it take one for
the team huh
take one for the team i throw a bike too
if you have to let go my bike you little
[ __ ]
dad i don't wanna do it you're just
chilling abuse you know
shut up i don't care god
come on don't grab my head you little
[ __ ]
dad please please i'm gonna throw you
if it's the last thing i don't grab it
there we go
come on i want to do it come on what do
you want to do you want to do me
you're so sick
come on don't run away son
i do another synchronized dance if you
just do this favor of me
and [ __ ] throw yourself dad i don't
want to go
let go a bike there we go
oh why i knew this was a bad idea
let's try it one more time africans oh
see my leg my leg is not attached to my
leg body
i'm still doing this that is what i call
badassery
but that is bleeding out of my ass oh no
it stopped never mind
never mind wow ah
[ __ ] sad we can make this hi i'm alive
every man why do i keep singing that
doll holy [ __ ]
whoa chicken knives yeah
[ __ ] hate this i [ __ ] hate that
all right
why do i keep clicking synchronize dance
why do i keep playing backwards hey
i made it alright this is cool this is
totally a regular
day for me you know got no legs but i'm
still still so i'm going
backwards and forwards i'm still i just
i don't even have any legs but i'm still
riding the bicycle how did you
this is what i call badassery right here
you think i care huh you think i care if
i don't have any legs i'm gonna go
anyway don't care about anything ah
no that would have been so epic god damn
it all right
finishing that boy or girl paul those
are stupid
let's try this one glass harpoon rum and
then
that was [ __ ] quick i [ __ ] made it
even
watch holy [ __ ] i gotta do that again
all right all right
don't die for once
how do you talk if you don't have any
head you little [ __ ]
go fast well done
ah no ah this is not supposed to happen
the hell is doing i'm spanking myself
yeah yeah
oh no i can't spank myself anymore what
the [ __ ] all right we can do this son
whoa whoa
oh so sorry so sorry did me to do that
ah
[ __ ] oh hey
how's it going i'm a unicorn i mean like
a
what the [ __ ] all right that was not bad
at all
all right let's try this one because i'm
free
free falling back flip ah
it's kind of comfortable here best buy
was here it would be a perfect day
that looks like a penis let me grab it
hey i'm alive that's cool don't need a
lower body to do this
no no hey we
come back together we are reunited you
and i
leg i know you can't run away from me
leg
all right fraud what's the pack what
that makes no sense
all right let me just get comfortable
grabbing the penis
and then we drop whoa whoa whoa i need
to change
all right front oh hey
oh [ __ ] that did not go very well
come on ah grab it like bite horns
there we go there we go and then you
land here
don't let go there we go there we go
and then we shake it shake why did you
shake it why everything was fine until
you shake it
come on we can do this i know we can i
know you love me
i know uk shout out i'm so passed
no you know why would you be pissed all
right there we go there we go
i didn't oh i made it no i lost my arms
[ __ ]
god damn it i don't think i can do this
one brush
after i get into here because i recorded
a lot and you know these things do
happen
anyway that's pretty much it like make
sure you enjoyed subscribe to comment
below today and i'll see you tomorrow
oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] that was loud
it's my [ __ ] oh
that's why y'all